Trascrizione: Alberto Pagani
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Quello che vi vorrei presentare
è quanto siamo stati in grado di fare
fino ad ora
al di là dei confini della Terra
e che cosa c'è
al di là dei confini della Terra.
Questa foto in qualche modo
lo testimonia:
è la Stazione Spaziale Internazionale.
È il più grande laboratorio internazionale
mai costruito.
È grande più o meno
come un campo da calcio,
per darvi le dimensioni,
e orbita a 400 km sopra le nostre teste.
Questa foto in particolare
è stata scattata
dall'astronauta italiano Paolo Nespoli
che è stato per ben 6 mesi
sulla Stazione Spaziale Internazionale
e che ha scattato questa foto
mentre a bordo
di una capsula russa, la Soyuz,
si era appena staccato dalla stazione
e rientrava verso terra.
Una breve introduzione su chi sono
è data da questa foto che mi ritrae
a maggio del 2009
con i sei nuovi astronauti europei
che avevamo appena selezionato.
Questo era appunto
l'annuncio di questa impresa,
nella mia funzione di direttore
del volo umano
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea.
La cosa interessante
è che di questi sei astronauti
ben due sono italiani:
Luca Parmitano è quello più a sinistra
e Samantha Cristoforetti
è facile da individuare
poiché è l'unica donna
del corpo astronauti europeo.
Torniamo alla Stazione
Spaziale Internazionale (ISS)
dove si fanno una serie di esperimenti,
sia all'interno dei moduli pressurizzati
dove essenzialmente
si eseguono esperimenti
dove abbiamo vantaggio
dall'avere condizioni di assenza di peso.
Fisiologia, biologia, scienza
dei materiali e dei fluidi.
Ma anche tutti gli esperimenti
per quanto riguarda
l'osservazione dello spazio profondo:
esperimenti di cosmologia, astrofisica
e ovviamente guardiamo anche alla Terra,
soprattutto per questioni
di osservazioni della Terra
legate al cambiamento climatico.
Ma anche per guardare quanto
la presenza dell'uomo
sulla superficie del nostro pianeta
cambia un po' la costruzione
di quello che è poi
il futuro del nostro pianeta.
Questa è una bellissima immagine,
mentre la stazione spaziale
orbitava sopra l'italia
che la vedete sullo sfondo,
presa dalla cupola,
che è una sorta di finestra sul mondo
che utilizzano gli astronauti sulla ISS,
tra l'altro un oggetto di tecnologia
costruito in Italia.
Questa è una bellissima immagine
presa sempre da Paolo Nespoli
dove si vede ancora l'Italia
nella parte sud,
sempre da uno degli oblò della cupola.
E questa è invece Roma di notte.
La cosa interessante è che noi riusciamo
con queste fotografie,
oltre a essere bellissime,
a vedere nel tempo come cambia
il fenomeno della presenza dell'uomo.
Come l'antropizzazione può cambiare
le condizioni del nostro pianeta.
Ma ci sono anche delle cose
molto interessanti
e anche un po' peculiari.
Questa è un'immagine che mostra
l'intersezione delle scie
lasciate dagli aerei.
Mostra quindi
qual è il traffico che c'è nei cieli.
È un'immagine
appunto presa dalla stazione,
non sarebbe stato possibile avere
una conoscenza di questo genere,
visiva, fotografica,
da un'altra postazione.
Qui invece siamo a un volo Shuttle,
questo era il penultimo volo Shuttle.
Come sapete, a luglio
è stato purtroppo chiuso il programma.
Questo è un volo a maggio
e la bellezza di questa immagine
è che in realtà è stata presa
da una passeggera su un aereo di linea.
L'aereo era in ritardo
e la signora dormiva nella sua postazione,
e quando si è svegliata dall'oblò dell'aereo
ha visto questa immagine stupenda.
La cosa interessante
che volevo sottolineare,
a parte la bellezza dell'immagine,
è che in realtà qui stiamo ormai
parlando di fotografie
che vengono prese da altri oggetti,
o da persone
che non sono sulla superficie della Terra.
Quindi ci stiamo piano piano
allontanando dai confini della Terra,
che è un po' il filo conduttore
di quello che sto cercando dire
in questi pochi minuti.
Questa invece è un'immagine presa
sempre da Paolo Nespoli dalla ISS.
Vedete sull'angolo in alto a destra
il braccio robotico della stazione,
un po' sfocato
perché lui era appunto vicino.
Lo sfondo in basso non è che la Terra,
come al solito,
e vedete quella scia centrale:
quella scia corrisponde al lancio
di un veicolo cargo europeo
che abbiamo lanciato, tra l'altro sotto
la mia responsabilità a febbraio,
dalla base di Kourou, in Guyana Francese,
dove c'è lo spazioporto europeo.
È un cargo che serve a rifornire
gli astronauti a bordo della stazione
di quanto gli serve per sopravvivere,
vale a dire che a parte gli esperimenti,
gli mandiamo acqua, cibo,
suppellettili e tutto quello
che gli può servire in quella situazione
per passare i sei mesi
di permanenza sulla stazione.
Ancora un'altra foto dalla stazione,
di un oggetto
che stava raggiungendo la stazione.
Questa invece è sempre la ISS,
ma è un'immagine radar della stazione
ed è presa da un satellite
che si chiama TerraSAR-X,
un satellite tedesco
per l'osservazione della Terra peraltro,
che ha puntato sulla stazione
e come vedete
anche un'immagine radar
vi dà la possibilità di riconoscere
i pannelli solari, la struttura centrale
e tutti gli altri elementi.
Di nuovo un veicolo automatizzato,
una sonda,
in orbita che riprende
la stazione spaziale in orbita.
Per fare un discorso un po' più ampio,
la cosa importante da ricordare
in questa situazione
è che il nostro pianeta,
e quindi il nostro sistema solare,
è in realtà parte di un sistema più ampio
che è la nostra galassia, la Via Lattea.
Questa è una simulazione.
Come vedete,
è una tipica galassia a spirale,
vale a dire
con dei bracci che spiraleggiano.
Vediamo dove siamo noi:
vedete il centro
di questo sistema di riferimento,
lì c'è il nostro sistema solare.
Praticamente sui confini
di uno dei bracci a spirale,
che è distante circa 26 mila anni luce
dal centro della galassia.
Bene, come lo traduciamo in km,
26 mila anni luce?
Il numero in alto è la distanza
in chilometri di un anno luce,
che come sapete
è i chilometri che noi percorreremo
se viaggiassimo un anno
alla velocità della luce,
e il numero in fondo è la distanza in km
tra noi e il centro della galassia,
un numero assolutamente illeggibile.
Immaginate che ci sono sistemi solari
in tutta la galassia.
C'è praticamente
un numero di galassie enorme,
miliardi e miliardi nel nostro universo,
e chiaramente noi non sappiamo
quanti universi
sono presenti dove.
Si apre tutto un discorso
su "da dove veniamo",
"cosa siamo diventati"
e "cosa potremmo diventare"
che ovviamente
ha tutta una serie di implicazioni.
Questa è una bellissima immagine,
lo zoom di un'immagine
presa da terra in questo caso,
era uno degli osservatori a terra,
lo European Southern Observatory,
e vedete la ISS con lo sfondo del Sole.
Questa, sempre per parlare
di quanto accade in realtà
in continuazione
nel nostro sistema solare,
scusate, nella nostra galassia;
questo è il centro della nostra galassia
dove c'è un buco nero
che è circa 4 milioni di volte
la massa del Sole.
Qualcosa di abbastanza movimentato
al centro della nostra galassia.
Ripeto, la nostra galassia è una
dei tanti miliardi di galassie
che abbiamo nel nostro universo.
Ora, questa è un'immagine
dove la coppia del sistema Terra-Luna
ci dà la sensazione di quanto la Terra
sia effettivamente
sia un pianeta piccolo visto dall'esterno.
Questa è un'immagine presa
dal Voyager diverse decine di anni fa.
Questa invece è un'immagine
della Terra con la Luna
presa ancora dalla ISS.
Questa invece, Apollo 17,
dalla superficie della Luna
con la Terra che sorge.
Vi dà anche la relatività
rispetto al sistema di riferimento:
che cosa sorge e cosa non sorge
rispetto a dove si è sistemati.
E il passo successivo
non può che essere Marte.
Perché Marte?
Perché in realtà forse sapete
che in ogni sistema solare esiste
una cosiddetta zona abitabile,
una zona virtuale
all'interno della quale
i pianeti che ci si trovano
possono sviluppare
delle condizioni tali per cui
si possono formare
delle forme complesse di vita.
Nel caso della Terra,
che è appunto nella zona abitabile
del nostro sistema solare,
se essa fosse soltanto l'1%
più vicina o il 2% più distante dal Sole
non ci sarebbero più queste condizioni.
Il che vuol dire che probabilmente,
con l'andar del tempo,
con il sole che aumenterà di temperatura
per la sua evoluzione naturale
come nana bianca,
la zona abitabile si sposterà
naturalmente verso l'esterno,
quindi Marte entrerà nella zona abitabile.
D'altra parte, le caratteristiche
della superficie di Marte
sono abbastanza simili
in alcune situazioni.
Questo è Valles Marineris,
il più grande canyon di Marte,
molto simile a cose terrestri.
Questo è un deserto con delle dune.
Questo è invece un tramonto
preso dal veicolo mobile Spirit,
un rover della NASA, qualche anno fa,
dove vedete immediatamente
la dimensione del Sole.
Quindi anche se Marte
è mediamente a 60 milioni di km
di distanza dalla Terra,
vedete quanto è diversa
l'impressione che si ha della nostra stella
da un pianeta piuttosto che da un altro.
E Marte poi è praticamente vicino a noi.
Se io vi sfidassi a dire
qual è la Terra e qual è Marte,
probabilmente sarebbe
abbastanza difficile da individuare.
In realtà quello a destra è Marte
e quella a sinistra la Terra.
Quindi forse Marte è un pianeta
a cui bisogna puntare,
per cercare di capire il nostro futuro,
il futuro della razza umana,
in qualche modo.
In Europa, l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
ha avviato un progetto con i russi,
qui siamo alle porte di Mosca,
questa è una facility di simulazione
di questo programma
che si chiama Mars500
che è iniziato a giugno
dello scorso anno
e si sta per concludere.
Tenete conto
che un viaggio oggi verso Marte
richiede circa 7 mesi
con la tecnologia attuale,
poi una volta arrivati
sulla superficie di Marte
occorre attendere circa 18 mesi
affinché i due pianeti
siano nella posizione giusta,
e poi altri 7 mesi per tornare,
quindi circa due anni e mezzo.
Quindi abbiamo simulato
una missione di 520 giorni,
accorciando soltanto il tempo
di permanenza
sulla superficie di Marte,
il tempo simulato sulla superficie
di Marte, a 30 giorni,
e abbiamo messo sei cosmonauti
chiusi in questi bidoni, tre russi,
due europei e un cinese.
Questi sono due di questi cosmonauti,
quello a sinistra è europeo,
l'altro è russo.
Qui sono appunto equipaggiati
per un'attività extraveicolare
su questa superficie simulata di Marte,
e hanno compiuto una serie di esperimenti.
Questo ci serve per preparare
la missione umana vera verso Marte.
Una missione umana che non potrà
che essere internazionale
perché ormai non c'è più
un discorso di competizione.
Ci sono attività di collaborazione
a livello globale
dove insieme studiamo
qual è il modo per poter raggiungere
prima la Luna,
poi Marte e poi chissà... oltre.
Questo chiaramente fatto
nello spirito di conoscenza
anche per cercare
di capire che cosa ci circonda.
Chiaramente questa nostra attività
per il futuro
non può che essere
un'attività internazionale.
Quindi ci aspettiamo che nel 2025 - 2030,
se tutto va come pianificato,
noi potremmo avere
un primo equipaggio internazionale
sulla superficie di Marte.
Quando saremo su Marte,
quando arriveremo su Marte,
questo è quello che vedremo.
Quella sarà
la dimensione della nostra Terra,
e sarà interessante
perché a quel punto
la nostra Terra sarà non più piatta
come si diceva prima
ma un piccolo pallino blu lontano.
E forse a quel punto
ci renderemo tutti conto
di quanto è importante conoscere,
di quanto è importante capire
cosa c'è al di là dei confini della Terra.
Quanto è importante studiare,
quanto è importante capire come noi
riusciamo ad avere un impatto sulla Terra
per preservarla, ma anche muoverci
verso altri pianeti perché
è il futuro dell'umanità.
(Applausi)